julian let's bring in brandon judd
president of the national border patrol
council brandon welcome
mike thank you very much for having me
but let me start by saying every single
u.s citizen should be furious about the
actions of this administration trying to
overturn a policy that has been proven
to work and then of course they use
rhetoric instead of actual facts when
they say that it puts them under
unacceptable conditions well they don't
have any facts whatsoever or evidence to
prove that those conditions are
unacceptable that's simply rhetoric
they're trying to deflect from from
their issues from their failures on the
border and all this is going to do is
cause even more chaos and it's going to
put more pressure on our agents
to get the job done better when they
can't do it it's policy that dictates
what we're able to do
why in your view brandon is remaining
mexico so effective
because the cartels understand and they
recognize all of our movements they
surveil us they watch us they know how
many agents we have in the field at any
given time they understand that if they
flood a certain area with a large number
of illegal immigrants it takes more of
our agents out of the field and when
they do that they're able to cross their
higher value products i mean just look
at what happened yesterday the cbp said
that uh that a tweet by chief patrol
agent chris clem out of yuma arizona
was law enforcement sensitive that was
not law enforcement sensitive that was
information that the american public
should have has a right to know and yet
cbp forced him to take that tweet down
because it was embarrassing to this
administration because that's what the
cartels do that's why mpp is so
important the the criminal cartels do
not they do not fear law enforcement
what they fear is policy they fear if
they're going to be prosecuted they fear
if mpp is going to be brought back
because then they can't go into
countries and advertise their services
and make billions of dollars off of our
policies i want to play a clip from
former acting dhs secretary chad wolfe
and i'll have you respond
we know that the bite administration
doesn't like the policy
this latest ploy to ask the supreme
court to overrule it is yet another
issue with their messaging you can't
implement the program and at the same
time say that you want to dismantle the
program and think that that is going to
resonate with migrants and cartel
members and other smugglers
why is the administration so eager to
have the supreme court step in here
they're pandering to their open border
base they understand that they have a
huge problem their numbers are
underwater in every single category
whether it's the economy border security
foreign affairs they're underwater and
everything so they're trying to energize
their base that's all they're doing the
only good thing
that we can fall back on is we know that
the supreme court is going to rule
against the administration because the
mpp is perfectly lawful so therefore you
know we're in a good position there but
all this does is allows the
administration to slow walk the
re-implementation the mpp which is what
they're trying to do
it sounds like the problem is extending
beyond texas and arizona there are now
questions being asked in pennsylvania
about immigrants being flown in there
what do you know about the situation in
pennsylvania
and other states far beyond texas and
arizona
this is happening every single day when
we take
children in custody or unaccompanied
minors in custody we turn them over to
health and human services and they then
fly them throughout the united states
including pennsylvania and they do it
under the cover of night because they
don't want the american public to
understand what's going on now the
reason why this is so scary is all we
have to do is look at florida and we
have to look at that 24 year old that
claimed he was 17 year old years old
when when he was apprehended by the
border patrol and then he was flown to
florida and he killed francisco javier
his his um uh not his stepfather but the
the home that the health and human
services placed him in that's why it's
so scary and that's why the american
public should have a right to know
exactly what this administration is
doing but because it's embarrassing they
don't let the public know and they try
to hide it under the cover of night
brandon judd thanks very much for your
time
anytime thank you